it's great to welcome to the program
today Steven Hassan who is one of the
leading authorities on cults and
mind-control he's the founder of the
freedom of mind resource center and also
author of the book the cult of Trump a
leading cult expert explains how the
president uses mind-control so first of
all it's great to have you on I think
maybe a good place to start is when we
talk about mind control in the way you
talk about Donald Trump using it you
know last week we talked to someone who
researched CIA mind control programs
that's not the same type of mind
controlled that you're talking about
right so actually in my book I talk
about MKULTRA and CIA mind control
research when I'm doing a historical
like how did we get to where we are here
yes and so it is very relevant also
because the CIA in the early days of
this of this research I should say the
research came about because of communist
brainwashing which of the term was
coined in the 50s and military
intelligence was sending people to say
what are the communists doing to get
people to renounce their allegiances to
turn in their family members and friends
so people like Robert liftin Margaret
singer Edgar Schein Louis Jolliet and
West were the four big people who when I
was first the program from the Moonies
I read their material and met with them
and they said holy mackerel what you're
describing in the Moonies is so much
more sophisticated than what we study in
the 50s and they were very encouraging
me though to learn more and share with
them yeah I mean yeah that MKULTRA part
of what they were studying along with
LSD was hypnosis and they do have a
section in the book about hypnotic
methods indirect methods and also the
use of language to deliberately elicits
powerful emotional states
and vivid visual descriptions in
people's minds the use of repetition
over and over and over again to enforce
the black and white all or nothing good
versus evil mindset and in my book I
really tried to cover the basic ground
of of making the case that that Donald
Trump acts like a stereotypical cult
leader has the malignant narcissist that
characteristics does the pathological
lying doesn't have the empathy never
takes responsibility you know I go
through all of the patterns as well as
because people are saying I have friends
I have relatives who are really smart
they're very educated but they're
totally into Trump they're totally
captivated and think you know that he's
the answer to God or the answer to all
the life's problems and that's exactly
the mindset I had when I was in the Moon
cult in the 70s yeah I mean given that
experience what do you see that it is
that pulls people that seem very
intelligent they often seem more
intelligent than Donald Trump himself
what is it that is happening is it is it
message is it personality is it tactics
like what or is it a combination of
these a combination of all of the above
so the first thing is that I want to
state is that my work involves
trafficking victims people in political
called therapy cults religious cults
even cults a personality where the
person is really subjugated by another
person afraid to make them upset with
them that they may want to get revenge
or harm them so the the point for me
with Mike destructive mind control is
you can't have that applied in a
negative way without the use of
deception because no one no intelligent
educated person would say I want to be
deceived I want to be exploited in arms
I want to I want to have my critical
analytic
mind dismantled when it comes to you
know how I how I behave so it's it's a
bi-directional process between the
influencer and the influence II however
in the United States where we're dealing
with digital media we're dealing with
Breitbart news Fox News religious
Broadcasting Network the Trinity
Broadcasting Network and and one
Universal that I see is that people who
are only listening to one partisan
viewpoint and getting all their
information that fits into one of the
four components of mind control which I
call information control especially if
that information is propagandistic
doesn't care about what's factual and
what's provable and that appeals to
emotions particularly fear and I talked
about the universal mind control
technique of phobia indoctrination which
in the mind of somebody under mind
control they can't imagine you know
criticizing the leader or leaving the
group and being happy and fulfilled they
can only imagine a disastrous world with
this this deep state cabal that that's
filled with traffickers you know that
that are going to destroy America as we
know it etc so that makes a lot of sense
when it comes to some of the just set
general public followers of the
president I'm curious whether when you
look at the way that a lot of the
Republican Party at least claims to have
fallen in line with Donald Trump are
they subject to the same source of
influences or are they just sort of
playing a role because they've decided
it's palete politically expedient and
advantageous and they're not really
falling for it so that's a very good
question and the answer is I don't know
we'd have to kind of analyze
person-by-person
yeah
and involvement by involvement but what
I did learn when I was researching this
book this year is that there are very
powerful cultic groups that are
influencing Donald Trump and I believe
giving him instructions
it's these groups that actually have
millions of followers that are his base
these are air quotes that are his base
and that these folks are following their
leadership who's saying we need to
follow Trump and the minute those those
leaders change their mind and decide
that Donald isn't following God or isn't
doing God's will on earth they're gone
what groups are those so in my book I
have to start with the obvious Putin and
and the Russian influence is definitely
influencing Donald Trump in my in my
research as well as all the russian
émigré x' around the world who are
listening to russia TV they're also Minh
indirectly implementing that but then I
get into a secretive cult called the
family or the fellowship the two
best-selling books by Jeffrey Charlotte
were written about this cult it's been
around in the United States for 80 years
it too was created in the Cold War era
to fight godless communism to create a
group for Jesus except it's not the
traditional understanding of Jesus this
is an appeal to elitists people who have
powerful wealthy individuals and they've
been manipulating the United States
government policy domestically as well
as as foreign for 80 years there's a
wonderful document docu-series that Jeff
Sharlet did for Netflix family that I
would highly recommend then so Michael
Pence was recruited into the family by
truck Colson who
is a convicted Watergate felon and he
was intense was involved with bringing
in the cabinet members so this is a
direct influence as well then I get into
Opus Dei which is a catholic right-wing
secretive cult that it appears Attorney
General William Bar is involved with and
can help explain why he would not be
representing honestly the Moller report
the substance of the Muller report or
his lecture at Notre Dame lost school
recently about the need to get more
Christianity into American members mind
citizens Minds then I go into one of the
scariest groups and this is a
conglomerate of organizations I call the
New Apostolic Reformation or I should
say they call at that these are groups
where the leader says they're an apostle
or a prophet who gets direct revelations
from God they typically speak in tongues
they cast out demons they do faith
healing they stay up all night praying
and fast for long days and and they're
very high-tech and there's at least 10
million Americans and when the media
talks about Trump's base and calls them
white evangelical Christians in my
opinion I know white evangelical
Christians and they're aghast at what is
being promulgated from the White House
and and their policies against
immigration for example this is this
it's this cultic group that I'm very
concerned about because they've been
told that Trump is a sinner yes but he's
like a King Cyrus figure and God is
using him to advance the agenda of
breaking down the separation of church
and state in order to impose what
Christian white Christian view on
America and then we get into all rights
and we get into libertarians sure yeah
which were
are familiar with as sort of more
well-known political groups so in the
somewhat limited time we have left
you were deprogrammed what is it that
works to deprogram people from cult
beliefs because what we do seem to know
is that hammering them over the head
with facts does not seem to work often
appeals to values backfire if just uh or
sometimes fail altogether what are the
successful sort of characteristics of
deprogramming right so first of all I I
kind of flinch a little bit with the
term deprogramming because humans are
not computers I used it because you had
used it that that's the term the media
likes to use I was truly deprogrammed in
1976 after a near-fatal van crash
they took my crutches away so as being
held against my will you know and I've
gone on to do voluntary interventions
but the key is you're absolutely right
you can't say anything directly critical
against the leader the doctrine or the
group because the triggers thought
stopping which is one of the mind
control techniques makes people
defensive it actually makes them feel
persecuted and more more deeply embedded
so the best thing to do is to is to
create a warm relationship with the
person say I respect you you're
intelligent you're educated help me
understand how you came to have the
beliefs that you have now when did you
first hear about Donald Trump did you
watch The Apprentice where you are a fan
or did you you know ever hear of him
before he started running for the GOP
and and and essentially and this was
happened with me in the moon cult is I
was sure I wasn't brainwashed I was a
hundred percent sure but I was open to
hearing about Chinese communist
brainwashing techniques so I was open to
going through Lifton's
eight criteria I've developed a model
called the bite model which stands for
behavior control information control
thought control and emotional control
you go through the components about this
other group not the one you're in
communism orts or traffickers how do
traffickers groom and indoctrinate
people to be sex slaves or labor slaves
and then then you ask that you tell them
look the only way to really reality test
is to actually talk to critics and
former believers and really reflect over
your own experience are you blocking
automatically any critical thought
against the leader the doctrine or the
group or not and and the truth is in my
experience I've been doing this work for
43 years is that nobody wants to be a
fool nobody wants to be conned and and
when they see you know what I believed
what I believe based on what I was told
what my experiences was but now I have
more information I can change my mind
and I'm not a bad person for changing my
mind I can go yeah you know darn moon
isn't the Messiah
you know I was brainwashed those two and
a half years yeah that's super
interesting because it combines number
one the starting from a point of empathy
which former white supremacists have
described to me as extremely useful with
some of the techniques
honestly that that remind me of Dale
Carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people which is let people
believe lead people to believe they are
deciding to change their mind even if
you are sort of in some way
participating and opening the door for
them to find that truth themselves it's
an interesting combination of tactics
yeah it's not a Dale Carnegie technique
it really comes from my own experience
tour and and it's genuine that I really
do believe that people deep down inside
want to know the truth absolutely I want
to be manipulated and lied to they will
respond to respect and love and you know
convinced me yeah there's also like an
element of what this guy Anthony Magna
Bosco calls Street epistemology which is
just having conversations with people
about getting them to talk about how
they came to believe the things they
believe without necessarily challenging
any particular belief head-on right so
the
the key in terms of my methodology and
they've written three other books before
I wrote the cult of Trump the the the
key is really educating people about
what we know about the human mind of
what we've learned about social
psychology how we for example are our
prime to follow our peers that we
identify with even if they're saying the
wrong size line that we can see with
their own eyes
two-thirds of everyone doing the Asch
conformity study start agreeing with the
wrong answer or people following who
they think is a legitimate authority
figure might start administering shocks
to the point where they may electrocute
another human being yes the room and
they're hearing screams help me my heart
but they keep following the authority
figure it's understanding social
psychology that we're human beings that
our minds can be influenced and also
understanding that your net not a bad
person if you've been in in programmed
with bad beliefs we've been speaking
with Steven Hassan who is one of the
leading authorities on cults and
mind-control make sure to check out the
book the cult of Trump a leading cult
expert explains how the president uses
mind-control steven such a pleasure
having you on today yeah thanks so much
David